A Pentagon report is
detailing a dramatic increase
in UFO sightings.
More than 350 since 2021.
Many of them are explained
as being drones, birds or weather events.
But about half of them
remain unexplained.
And the office
that tracks these sightings
and restricted
military airspace
says that some, quote,
require further analysis.
That's an understatement.
CNN's space and defense
correspondent Kristen
Fisher has the details.
Boris and Amara,
Capitol Hill
has been waiting for this report
from the office of the Director
of National Intelligence or the DNI.
And what this report found
is that there have been more than 300
new sightings
of what
the government calls UAPS or unidentified
aerial phenomena
or more commonly called UFOs.
Since the last time that the DOD
and I
put out a report
like this back in 20, 21.
Back then,
the odd and I could not explain 144
sightings of UAPs this time.
Now they can't explain 171 of them
in one part of the report
that really stands out is this one.
It says that
some of these uncharacterized UAPs
appear to have demonstrated
unusual flight characteristics
or performance capabilities
and require further analysis.
So is it advanced U.S.
technology,
is it advanced technology from
a foreign adversary
like perhaps China or Russia,
or is it
extraterrestrial in origin
or something else entirely?
We just don't know.
And the U.S.
government
says that it doesn't know either,
or at least it will not say so
publicly in this unclassified report.
But they did give some explanations for
about 163 of the sightings
that have been detailed in this report.
And here's how they explained those
The vast majority
are either balloons or balloon entities.
A handful were drones.
Another handful were what they called
airborne clutter, things like birds,
weather events
or airborne debris, like plastic bags.
So the bottom line
here, members of Congress say
that this is a
step in the right direction
to reducing the stigma
associated with reporting
sightings of UAPS.
It's also a step in the right direction
to enhancing national security,
because remember,
a lot of these sightings happen
right around military bases or assets but
while it's a step in the right direction,
members of Congress
say the Pentagon,
the Office of the director
of National Intelligence,
still have a long way
to go to giving them
the answers that they ultimately want.